a big part of the conversation that
happens in the manosphere and the red
pill movement is the concept of a high
value man and you're referenced all the
time people say Patrick by David is a
high value man
um what does that mean to you to you
you've been very successful in business
what defines what qualities make a high
value man so the characters at the
bottom at the you know Foundation of his
character and character to me it's many
different things keeping your word you
know if you're going to say you're going
to do something you do it you know uh
being consistent being respectful
showing up leading in any situation you
can being willing to do the work you
know constantly working on yourself
character says a lot about an individual
I hire you could have no hard skills
none at all you could have no degree but
if you got a strong character we're
going to be all right Kai when he came
to us he didn't have a degree it was an
18 19 year old kid that flew out from
Norway for a job interview and I'm
telling Mario what's this guy doing
flying out for Norway yeah do you know
how many times I've had a 45 minute face
time with his mom or his dad from Norway
they'll call me we'll be on the phone
together talking his mom and dad were in
town the other day and we had dinner I
took him out to Casa D'Angelo and I have
five kids of which for them are doctors
or gonna be doctors and one of them is
Kai okay when you talk to Kai you sense
values and principles and strong
character I don't need to meet the
parents to know who the parents are just
by meeting Kai I know who the parents
are when you meet the mom and dad who've
been married together for 31 30 to 33
years he's a chiropractor she's a
teacher they live in Norway she was from
America they met they got married they
got five beautiful kids you know that
part allows me to trust the individual
and forgive them more because they are
coming from a very strong character
that's a part of being a strong man the
other part is you got to be an earner
you can't rely on the government you
can't rely on your parents you can't
rely on anybody to take care of you you
got to pay your bills you got to make
your money you got to pay your taxes you
got to be a net positive to society
where you're contributing to society
people around you have to feel like
they're protected if you're there and
you know if you want to take it to a
whole different level your body's got to
be in shape you can't be sloppy you
can't be out of shape you can't be
somebody that's coming home every night
at five o'clock having a beer hey turn
on the TV and I'm just watching news
having chips no one respects somebody
like that I mean we can have respect for
anybody but nobody looks at somebody
like that saying oh my God you're such
an impactful uh you know person to
society we broke it down about six weeks
ago I'm writing this new business book
with uh penguin and we created a system
on how we look at leaders people who are
leaders we've got two different types of
three different types of citizens in any
society one is the lowest level which is
bad citizen a bad citizen we all know
what they do they don't pay their bills
they don't take care of their family
they don't take care of their kids they
don't do their stuff so that's a bad
citizen you can Define them very easily
then you have the good cities a good
citizen has a strong character and they
have some kind of a hard skill hard
skill is what you're a plumber hard
skills you know how to code you know how
to edit you know how to cut you know how
to shoot you know how to do certain
things you got a hard skill then the
impactful person in a society is a
person that's got soft skills what does
soft skills mean I can give a tough
message to you
in a proper way while you receive it
where somebody else will give that same
message and offend you a a person needs
to learn how to like this is the one
thing I think that Tate is working on
right now where he's trying to change
someone he's saying it himself where I
want to be able to deliver my message in
a more concise way
and that requires soft skills okay so
I'm going to deliver the message and I'm
going to do my best to give it to you
know in a way that you're going to be
able to receive it and a last but not
least is you know in life you can have
many uh events that is going to cause a
paradigm shift you know one is getting
married one is having kids first time I
cried having a kid was with my Center
because I didn't cry with tikon I was
just so happy when I had two boys but
with Sena I stood over Jen I had tears
I'm like wow I'm excited about having a
girl it's very emotional Center it was
something different with Senna and then
obviously Brooklyn but moments you're
going to have in your life where you
have a paradigm shift you have to
internalize those moments because it
could produce a certain fire and a juice
in your life that can introduce you to
new version of you you've never met
before and these Paradigm shifts are not
all positive it could be a setback it
could be a breakup it could be a death
in a family it could be getting publicly
humiliated it could be getting fired it
could be you know somebody saying
something behind your back who you loved
who was you thought they were supported
but you heard them saying something and
you're hurt by this in those moments one
can have a paradigm to shift to say well
maybe they're right what do you want to
do about it maybe we got to get better
maybe maybe I am lazy maybe I'm not
working that or maybe it is my fault
when you're by yourself publicly we may
not admit to but probably gonna be like
I want to do something about this part
in those moments if you don't use those
unique moments because they don't come
too often if you don't use those unique
moments to really tap into the emotion
and do something big with your life it's
a lost opportunity so Tate to me I feel
he's had a lot of those publicly
humiliating moments or heartbreaks and
he's used that to put it here and then
he's won so I would say that's what I
would call a net positive as a man if
you want to watch the full episode
you're going to click right here and if
you want to ask me a question one on one
you want to do a one-on-one FaceTime
with a group of your friends whatever
you want you need to download minute
right now click right here and let's get
talking
foreign
[Music]